we want so we're gonna book him for for
a show okay to speak not more couple no
no like an Asian American like okay
panel right something he's used to doing
when he shows up it's a 911 deniers
group
[Music]
welcome back to a
extremely important episode of careful
boys today we have Chris and Farina with
us oh hello
we are currently off the Record and
that's good because we have to talk
about something that should not go on
the record for very special reasons oh
no but we're being filmed what is the
perfect prank we can pull on Anthony
Wow Let's plan this out because when he
gets back
well this we had to do the prank and
then this video had to go out
oh you want to do like it could be part
of the vid well what's our budget how
long has he gone for I mean he'll
probably be here next time if it's
Anthony I'm prepared to spend the whole
annual budget and reducer guys just pay
buy another 40 and you're gonna
liquidate Furniture yes yeah whatever it
is let's do it you were saying something
pretty good a second ago you said you
wanted to tell them that JK was over or
something yeah so we're we're like hey
dude JK it's done it sucks man I mean I
did call it six months ago
I was kind of right about that but here
and here we are and so like yeah and
then um so yeah anyways so yeah it's
been real thank you very much but then
like we all keep filming together
that would be hilarious and he just sees
the uploads yeah because we've been
having so much fun haven't we not been
having a lot of fun without him been in
Hawaii
wearing like samish outfits like that's
fine I wore the same kind of stuff
anyway we should get a new guy to host
like a completely new guy but very
similar to Anthony yeah yeah
[Laughter]
is there a particular guest that he
would like flip do we get Jackson can we
get Jackson away Jackson wins but then
we get like but he knows Jackson I'm
talking about a guy that he would be
like but doesn't he idolize Bobby
hundreds
yeah yeah yeah and we specifically we
already had him to have them without
Anthony leader that'd be funny to get a
guess that he would love to be here for
but he's not yeah yeah who would it be
Rihanna Beyonce oh I could probably make
that work yeah yeah we should get a deep
fake of Beyonce he wouldn't [__] know
dancer braids are different so he'll
think he'll think it's like even though
it's like a little wobbly he won't know
Beyonce oh dude how about how about we
do something where like
we uh this is so elaborate if we set up
some kind of an article right and then
we go oh there's a video corresponding
to this article we play the video and
it's really just a bunch of cameos of
famous people [__] on Anthony oh
[__] that's a really good one that's
really good we could pay it dude we
could pay out
we'll get Lance Bass dig it up a chicken
there's a bunch what's the cheapest
Cameo we can get dude dude they're so
cheap right now did you see that reduced
list yeah yeah oh my God taizon days
like 28 bucks oh bro that's sick he gets
like chocolate rain I got him I got him
on my phone yeah we'll just do you think
we'll be able to have them for a whole
guest instead of just like on Cameo what
do you mean taizon day yeah no like all
those reduced list guys hello Anthony
Lee
I guess you're not gonna be on just
getting news anymore
hire them to fire Anthony
Chocolate Rain JK news is over
yeah congrats it's all your creative in
but all right he's like chocolate Ray JK
news is over can we do like a physical
prank where like he walks in and I don't
know the floor caves in or something
just like that
his name Eric Eric Andre yeah we could
do Eric Andre type things I was um well
you have like a chainsaw guy come in
here
dude we get a special effects makeup
artist we have a chainsaw guy coming
here and he just decapitates all of them
he's horrified yeah horrified right and
then we all sit up and called the [__]
can we stage like an argument or like a
robbery or something oh robbery
and then and then he gets scared and he
runs outside trips and falls and he
breaks his legs and he can't dance yeah
he can't dance or we get
we get fans like we find them and then
we're just filming normal and the fans
line up and he has to do autographs or
something
obsessed with him or bring his exes on
dude I'm meet and greet
the only line is for Steve and not
Anthony oh we paid fans to come in line
up in the Steve
[Applause]
yeah yeah yeah we do a JK meet and greet
where everyone gets their own line but
we pay we tell if you're gonna come you
have to only line up at Steve's table
out there and Steve is right next to
Anthony and the only the only thing you
can the fans can do is they have to
ignore Anthony no ask him to hold the
camera you take the picture they can't
even make eye contact basically my hard
photographer yeah all day oh my God
that's so good and they have no idea who
he is like hey like do you know oh cool
yeah damn oh my you could put some
tables out there we'll all line up
everyone can go down the line and
everyone just skips Anthony we have like
actual Flyers we sign God his table's
left everyone leaves right after or we
could stage something you know he always
wants to go with a driving range what if
we stage something with like a actor
where he like beefs it with him over
like a club or like his spot he's like
hey man I usually I usually swing off
that it's my spot that's my spot and
it's like a Tom Harley Hardy or like a
real one like a real actor that he's
like oh my God that we know
anything here get like some buff dude to
like have beef with them and we're all
like trying to stay out of it [__] I
don't think Anthony would fight though
well he doesn't have to fight he's a guy
who's gonna get a hardcore Boulder yeah
yeah he's in a bulldog she didn't want
to fight dude
that'd be kind of funny it's not bad or
maybe he does stand up to him and he
looks back like you're gonna protect us
right and then we run yeah we're not
there we're like oh no dude you're on
your own bud sorry let me just do that
what about we take him golfing and when
he hits the ball it [__] explodes
and then he's he's just covering soot
that you see his eyes like cartoons
yeah he's completely covered in Black
Anthony is like doesn't like doing
JK news
before coming here dude I got it we we
bring a guest like a surprise guest
Midway through the day so he doesn't
like he'll just they'll just cold walk
in and it'll be a little person
and they're like hey what do you want to
throw me yeah but it's dressed up as us
like they're all dressed up yeah
it's about
Little People versions yeah we get up
like all right I think we're gonna have
a relief pitcher come in all right guys
like something my buddy for his birthday
he was like Hey I want to hire some
little people for my birthday you can do
it and I was like I was like what he
sends us the [__] link to the website
and it's a whole full service for
birthday little people for little people
yeah old little people
they'll box each other from like 800
bucks or something like that like it's
[__] crazy though that's Anthony's
like dream dude I'm gonna send you that
link that's Anthony's dream what do you
think about it could be the thing yeah
figure this out or they're hiding in his
arcade machine when he starts playing it
they just pop out oh I got one let's
pretend that we wanna we want him to
speak on a panel
okay we want so we're gonna book him for
for a show okay to speak at more couple
no no like an Asian American like okay
panel right something he's used to doing
when he shows up it's a 911 deniers
group
and he's the [__] keynote speaker
yeah and everyone there is like
prominent like guys that roll books
around 9 11. I was inside a job and then
they introduced Anthony so he introduced
Anthony Lee as one of the prominent
Asian Americans Loose Change live like
basically he's into performance he does
he's doing the dance the one you said
it's called the twins
he uses the Michael Jackson lean
technique and then he brings it back up
he's like you think that's what happened
but it did it it's so good dude that's
amazing
fill it with people how come we're not
writing this stuff down dude right
we have interns who are doing that I
forget this is what this is yeah okay
that's a good a big strong Contender
that's called a banger yeah yeah 911 did
it really though
make them the billboard that's really
yeah really really strong 911 gets
served yes sir you got sir that's good
damn I like that can we do something to
his car I mean he's always parking it
out there he's not looking at it I mean
you know how to spit on cars yeah yeah
we get 30 dudes to spit on it that'd be
perfect
I I I could kind of get behind that I
hide a little person in the back and
cover them and then when he goes to
leave yeah we have a secret camera where
are we going I have a heart attack
he actually am I driving or we get him
at JK here and he's like on a hosting
day where he's kind of distracted and
we're like hey dude we've had like rats
or some [__] I don't know what's going
on we get a little person in a [__]
yeah in a rat costume oh [__] and we
have him like crawling through big holes
in the wall we already have holes
what the heck
we're gonna get a little person right in
the back of a car with [__] like a
choke choke wire and they're gonna try
to choke them and you oh what the [__]
are you doing and then the little
person's like you I heard on Jacob knees
you're trying to you don't you don't
like us yeah you think we're a [__]
joke he's only ever said he loves them
to get one like uh to wear like a almost
like a false trash can and just hide in
the bathroom and we just wait for
Anthony to go in there that'd be [__]
hilarious and we just have multiple
props throughout the day get one like
that and we could get one or or we just
do one out of the trash can right here
mid video we put the trash can in the
back and while he's hosting guy comes
out
like and it's like and we'll do like a
Hot Topic like a serious issue like say
it's on like abortion or something it is
abortion news and then he pops out
just to [__] you know some [__] that
he has to like really be focused on
you know what I mean no I think we
should get like a little person stripper
and Anthony has to tell tragic news
while he gets a lap dance
and we'll call it the little challenge
the little challenge dude
we get a 911 Survivor to come on the
show yes and confront him because it's
so [__] up yep like what he
perpetuates
cheese
a firefighter and then yeah we have the
survivors back
oh my God this guy's talking mad [__]
yeah
we're like this guys look this guy's
[__] toxic
I can't believe I can't believe what a
911 denier
dudes you think I wasn't [__] there
you don't think it happened and it's a
little person
I know you think we could get one wow a
little person that survived 911 I mean
you could hire a little person actor and
just have him say they did a person do
anything I do like that that's a whole
list Nick's got it send it
Spiderman it wasn't a Superman dude I'm
telling you the list of categories and
options they have on this website was
astounding it was something to Marvel at
dude it was it was a trip or hire kids
in a classroom and I like the him having
to speak on 911 like do a PowerPoint or
something for these kids
that's good that's so good and we
prepare the PowerPoint for him
Push the Button he's like here's why
dance is so important to the youth and
he clicks and is like why 911.
at this point he would never trust us to
do that no no you have to be clever yeah
it really it would just have to happen
yeah yeah there can't be like you could
get police showing up hire some cops and
they could like FBI aspirin oh they
could be like and he could be in trouble
for something It's gotta be an Ambler
who's Jeep Cherokee is that outside
that's a you fall for that instantly
yeah yeah a knock on the door two cops
yeah anybody anybody on that Jeep
Cherokee yeah exactly and then and then
and then all these cops come in and give
them a lap dance
[Applause]
and we pay him extra be like make sure
you get a hard dick in his face he loves
that [__] wait wait wait I can't tell if
we should get him maybe female strippers
though why why why because Anthony's gay
he might be like oh
titties dude so much so much of his
characteristics are just not true
we keep flip-flopping untrue he's he's a
gay 911 denier that hates little people
that sounds about right to me
everything's not a womanizer yeah and a
womanizer yep checks out you can go
ahead I mean honestly though if it was
female strippers he would have a worse
time yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think
yeah like he would be way more
uncomfortable if it was females yeah
big strong man and we both know why but
we don't need to say it that's true
because he's gay I like that one of like
two very convincing cops police officers
that are that are strippers and then and
then they milk the like the scariness
yeah they they arrest him tie him up and
then they just dude if he's handcuffed
already like it's something serious yeah
they handcuff him and then we sit them
down get the show started yo okay you go
first you go first you go first no no I
didn't have one of them okay we get a
guy to come in here right and he's like
he's like hey somebody here's one twenty
five thousand dollars and he's like and
it's we're looking for the the Shoemaker
who won 25 000. and then Anthony because
it's like yeah I have 25 000 in cash we
see it 25 000 cash for the Shoemaker and
when Anthony says it he's like you just
got served
you've been served oh he got shoes
you're being sued for 25 000. oh by
Bobby hundreds for copying the design of
the shoe yeah boom yeah triple Whammy
we call him in to work one day and
there's a foreclosed sign on the thing
it's shut down he shows up
him that's a closet and little people
yeah
oh let's go day after yeah
so in he send the link send it well you
know how Anthony's kind of like
pro-asian hate right yeah so
um
I kind of feel like what we should do is
well for one I don't think that's right
so we need to have an intervention yeah
that's like your personal thing right
you have to it's as as an Asian American
I think I have to stand up against Asian
hey and if he's the king of Asian honey
then I I got we got problems right so I
think we should propose that he gets the
keys to the city and we're in Good Old
Monterey Park and and since we have
connections to the mayor here maybe we
can invite
um Anthony for keys to the city of
Monterey Park but it's a it's really
just the intervention like when he shows
up we get all the Asian senior citizens
right there and we tell them this is the
man that's been beating up all the old
things all over town and now you need to
speak your mind on how you feel about
him yeah so I'm here I think that'll be
good and then the whole time they're
like thank you and then they're like
actually now we heard that you're a huge
perpetuator of Asian hey so here's the
community they want to tell you
something nervous yeah there it is I
think it's a standing on perfect yep and
then everyone just says [__] you
[__]
that's how the video is yeah
dude the funniest thing is remember when
he we had um we had that one Indian dude
who's like a finance guy oh
desperate desperate yeah and then
Anthony wasn't here when Jasper got here
so this guy's really serious right and
then um Jasper came he sat down and he
was like hey uh just to let you guys
know I I can't really like weigh in on
any raunchy stuff so um if that's okay
if you can be considerate of your humor
you know and we were like oh we got you
dude totally cool we're not gonna make
jokes like that Anthony then arrives
late and Cincinnati all right we gotta
catch up let's get this going starts and
would you rather [__] mom or dad well
he just keeps trying to make jokes and
we're not laughing at him we're just
like okay and Anthony was like what the
[__] all right
what the hell is wrong with you guys
we could do that for one day
just for uh what happened I did that for
seven years
but it would be funny if we set up a
certain like guest where
um you know we we we're all like aware
of one type of behavior and we hold it
yeah and we're totally different around
them yes then on it or something yeah
like we get like a like we get like a
like a priest or something like a
chaplain or something you know and then
and it was just here
to talk about God's stuff or or we get a
guest who's like cool with us and we
just tell them like someone who's kind
of scary looking someone's a little big
a little Burly man and we just tell him
before yeah when Anthony's hosting like
hey just like if he says anything just
like flip out you get yeah get offended
like yeah Anthony yeah and then just
[__] dip out or something better yet
have you have the guy like compliment
his biceps
like damn like what's up and then just
see how he reacts he'll probably flirt
back yeah he'll be down yeah you know
why because
I don't know why I don't know but yeah
what do you think I know why we can have
someone to scare him to like either way
to be really like comfortable making
really mess up jokes and that guy's
playing along until Anthony jumps in and
then he just goes why'd you have to say
that man what the [__] does that mean
[__] that Joe pestered haha
funny like that huh you think I'm funny
I think I'm funny we get a we get like a
retired mobster yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
and then Anthony makes a joke and the
guy's like ha ha who's co-siding this
guy yeah yeah who's friend are you why'd
you say that and then we're all just
like oh yeah
so far they can sweat a little bit a lot
of good ideas guys and then the guy
flashes a piece and then we're all like
shoot him go ahead he's the one that
said it tell him
shoot murder him [__] [__] they don't
tell anybody
we have a guess we should have a guest
um start choking on something or
whatever and then Anthony has to give
him
[Laughter]
afterwards he he has a CPR we're like
yeah you kissed him dude yeah
CPR and then the guy's getting up the
guy is getting a massive boner
tongue his mouth
but we're recording it and we're like we
have footage of you being gay and we
play it forever dude
it's the intro to JK
and then the guy that's getting CPR
grabs the back of his head and goes
no he grabs the back of his head and he
goes blah blah
JK sound effects baby
a classic sound
the range is so good that it could be
something as elaborate as cops to just a
guy joking to kiss him to a guy getting
mad you know I think all these are funny
we just have to find a way to work it's
realistic 911 event
where's this event by the way we're
organizing it we're booking the event
we'll book a ballroom maybe Minnesota
theater
I'll get the Loose Change guy maybe a
few prominent members of the 911
Community yeah
you can even start it like serious like
you can start talking just like everyone
will have their scripts and when it's
his turn you can also have the audience
in on it where they can like Boo him
it's got to start with Anthony like it's
dark right yeah and there's a spotlight
and it's like all right it's go time
Anthony he starts the show he does his
dance right and as he's dancing we're
gonna project on the background like the
911 two Twin Towers like reappearing and
then like everything and in the back
it's gonna be saying [__] like did it
really happen though and all these
things right and everyone's like whoa
and then when Anthony's done with this
thing the panel has all the people we
asked them to sit down and then the host
comes out and says welcome to the 911
deniers
sponsored by Nazi Germany
foreign